Aaron Donald joins us here on the show
how you been Aaron I've been doing great
you bet last time I saw you was in the
tunnel after that wild 90 point combined
game between you and the 49ers yeah and
now things are even brighter for your
future compared for me how things are
now than it was entering week 16 last
year Aaron we winner you know we plan
for something now you know in just going
out there just perfect plan for just
just going out to plan first episode my
dad now we plan for something and trying
to go you know make a playoff run and
won a World Championship so um
definitely a good good fitness and this
locker room right now in this building
but we got to keep it up and key works
what were you able to do to Russell
Wilson that other teams where have not
been able to do this year era we did a
great job you know coaches had a great
game for us and I think yesterday you
know did a great job of executing and
bottling them up and getting to him
getting them down the secondary did a
great job with locking him guys down
making them reset and giving us time to
get off well a lot of folks talking
about what Shawn mcveigh's brought to
the equation what is Wade Phillips
brought to your personal equation Aaron
a lot you know I just think about me the
most calm guy but you know he's always
confident you know a guy they make a big
play and you look at how many but I
don't look pretty much don't worry we're
gonna fix it like it never seemed were
so you know you give us that confidence
and that's where that's the type of
coach when I got there and give it all
for and trying to make plays for so I'm
just a great coach and I'm just um
blessed that opportunity to work with
whoa well calm it yet confident and
dominant that sounds like you right man
trying to do my part that they have one
game so you know this one like this
honestly yet so it just feel good it'd
be a part of it and be doing it now
because it's definitely hard to win in
this league so we just gotta keep it up
well what does motivate you Aaron Donald
when you know that's what it went in you
know I feel like you know you could say
you want the stats and all that that's
good too but you know we did that and we
wasn't winning it's just a whole
different feeling when you're going out
weekend and we go and you got guys out
there flying around and you coming away
with big
and pick them on top of jell-o week week
in and week out so just this is just a
good feel what was your first impression
meeting Sean became you know when I got
the opportunity to talk to him you know
before everything not just him talking
to him and you know we talked about how
hold people accountable
you know I stand as a standard and
that's what we need it you know I have
fun but when it's time to work this time
I work late by lucky and you definitely
see it in locker room and on the field
you know out the practice you don't see
a biopsy or now you see guys on the job
don't actually work this little thing
like that day they go a long way that
they're showing so let's go back if you
don't mind in the summer though I mean
what was it like for you sitting at home
wanting a new deal while all this was
somewhat coming together
it was definitely stressful you know and
you know I love the game of football
obviously I want to be here but you know
business is business and just try to
handle the business out of things but
you know here now went in and you know
that'll take care of herself so just
happy to be reported on winning
organization right now so so when was
the last time you had a conversation on
this front as far as the business yes my
ages been handling it for me so it's
still and they still been going back and
forth so they're gonna handle it but my
main focus is doing my job one football
field and let my guys I don't matter
okay so right now I mean have you called
your agent to see what's going on on
that front at all or yeah you have to
talk if it gave me the breast what was
going on and everything like that so so
there are conversations between your
agent and the front office about locking
you up long term right now going on yes
yes okay and then meanwhile you're just
you're just balling out on the field I
mean this clam ball man his playing ball
that's it that's all I can't control
what I can control Aaron Donald okay I'm
Donald of the Rams joining me here on
the show what is it like being around
Todd Gurley I've heard about it I've
heard about it but what is it like being
around him and what does he exude for
this team you know funny guy jokester
not always talking but no even having a
great year you know definitely big
bounce-back year for him it may be done
throwing everything and a little bit
more
so I'm just proud of that guy I told him
I walked up to him I just told my
product was on just keep working man
because I'm scared a little for that guy
he definitely having an MVP type of year
so um I'm just proud she's proud to be a
port forward to seeing this and being on
his team and watching him grow so yeah I
mean he sort of has a godfather
mentality doesn't he Aaron I know like
an old-school sort of certainly I know
that's the way a lot of your colleagues
that are trying to defend him feel about
him in this league man he's tough -
football player you know it got there
and he could do it all he could catch
the ball and run a bomb and make things
happen one ball in his hand so you just
want to know special type players you
know one of the players they don't come
around too often so when you get it you
gotta just you know sit back and watch
him work okay what did that win mean
yesterday look I know when is a win you
take it one at a time etc but that just
seemed like there was a statement being
made during that game Aaron got a lot of
respect we got a lot of respect for
Seahawks and you know they've been a
been a top dogs in his division for a
while so um it's time for some new girl
to step up and I feel like you know
we're ready for that so you know it's
really Adolphe why we played them gather
we know with respect no definite when I
get russell wilson back there don't he
do so um we just went out there and
played a great game and then we need to
do to come up with a big one at their
home so that it was even a little more
special doing it cuz that's definitely a
tough place to win it and do it here how
we did it you know
definitely a big one for us okay and
what's your take on quarterbacks in this
league
Aaron soft strong where do you stand on
this subjective quarterback you know I
wish there start running as much as they
do and just let us get them but know
there's a lot of good quarterbacks in
this league and I respect them also okay
cuz I know every pass rusher just deep
down doesn't like you know like I mean
in all honesty I mean we want to talk
about let's go back to predecessors in
that uniform in the stadium in which you
play Aaron I mean Deacon Jones hated
quarterbacks he hated the
when even a quarterback got inducted in
the Hall of Fame he just didn't want to
be around them even Aaron do you share
that same sentiment at all no I'll say
that you know with the Amazon you know
the other team like the enemy anyway so
you gonna go out there are many but it's
all respect for them guys you know my
job is to get to them and get them down
so all right Aaron thanks for the call
appreciate it Congrats on that win and
we'll chat down a line maybe in the
playoffs all right appreciate you that's
forever
right back at you that's one of the best
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience